can you guess what I'm talking about it
has different types but it's not an
apple it can be pumped but it's not a
tire it contains cells but it's not a
jail it can be given but it can't be
wrapped what is it the answer is blood
blood runs through an intricate system
of veins arteries and capillaries that
is 100,000 kilomet long that's twice the
circumference of the earth but it takes
less than a minute for a drop of blood
to travel from the heart through our
body and back to the heart again when
we're resting the heart pumps a liter of
blood every 10 seconds and it beats on
average 75 times per minute in
comparison a blue whale's heart the size
of a small car beats five times a minute
crabs have blue blood earthworms and
leeches have green blood and whilst
humans have four main blood types dogs
have eight and cows over